- - Yeah! Eille! Pat!
EnEnlève ton gardien; tu vois
bibien qu'il a l'air tanné, là!
- - Je pense qu'il est encore
bobon pour deux championnats.
- - Han!
- - Il fallait
ququ'ils se réconcilient,
ilil fallait qu'ils remettent
leleurs choses à leur place.
MoMoi, je suis bien content de .
- - Parce que c'est bien
s's'ils se sont vraiment
réréconciliés dans la même vie.
- - On sort de pandémie,
c'c'est le temps de s'aimer pui,
dede voir ça, ça a fait du bien.
GrGrâce à une campagne de
pupublicité d'uber Eat, je sais
papas qui a eu l'idée, on va lui
poposer la question, de
réréconcilier Mario Tremblay et
PaPatrick Roy, c'est un bon cou.
MaMario Tremblay est avec nous.
BoBonsoir.
- - Bonsoir.
- - C'est une belle journée pour
vovous.
- - Effectivement, c'est une trs
bebelle journée. C'est une
cacampagne publicitaire qui a ft
vrvraiment parler les gens. Et
cocomme les commentaires qu'on a
enentendus tantôt, il était tems
dede se retrouver Pat et moi. Je
pepense que les Québécois étaiet
cocontents de mettre fin à cette
hihistoire. Monsieur Simon
ArArsenault avait tenté le terrn
avavec Patrick. Lorsqu'on m'a
apappelé, j'étais un peu
scsceptique. Vous voulais qu'on
fafasse une publicité lui et mo?
- - C'est le gars de l'agence?
CoComment s'est faite la réunio?
- - Lorsque Monsieur Simon
ArArsenault a tenté le terrain,l
a a été approché par Uber Eat pr
coconnecter Patrick et moi danse
mmême commercial. Il m'appelle t
meme demande si j'ai le goût de
fafaire un commercial avec Patrk
RoRoy. Je lui dis : êtes-vous
sésérieux? Ils ont dit que
MoMonsieur Arsenault avait parlé
avavec Patrick Roy et qu'il état
prprêt à le faire. Quand on a vu
leles scripts et tout ça, que
c'c'était un peu sarcastique,
c'c'est vraiment bien fait. On t
vrvraiment content de s'êêtre
reretrouvé.
- - Vous avait vu ces images 1
mimilliard de fois. On va les
reremontrer. Le 2 décembre 1995,
lele fameux match. Patrick Roy e
fafait compter début, jusqu'à
neneuf. On vous voit derrière le
babanc. Vous l'avait remplacé.
VoVous arriver cette année-là ac
leles Canadiens. On a décrit çae
101000 manières. Comme un combat
dede coqs, Patrick Roy n'est pas
cocontent de lui. Est-ce que vos
vovous êtes expliqué avant la
pupublicité? Lui avez-vous dit
popourquoi vous ne l'avez pas
enenlevé des filets?
- - Je pense que Patrick là quad
mmême très bien expliqué. Quand
mmême que Mario viendrait me die
ququ'il aurait dû m'enlever,
efeffectivement, j'aurais dû
l'l'emplir. Mais je voulais
atattendre un peu plus parce que
PaPatrick Roy à son statut. Et
PaPatrick de son côté dit :
j'j'aurais dû revenir au bas età
l'l'effort Mario le lendemain.Ça
fafait 25 ans et je pense que
l'l'important dans tout ça, c'et
lala réconciliation entre Patrik
etet moi. On est membre au même
clclub de golf en Floride. On se
rerencontrait et on ne se parlat
papas. C'est un peu malaise.
MaMaintenant ça va être chose du
papassé.
- - C'est vrai, vous vous étire
crcroisé mais jamais il n'y avat
eueu une discussion franche et
mmême une discussion entre vous
dedeux.
- - Non. On s'est croisé, on s't
didit bonjour r par contre, on t
papas des sauvages, mais jamais
cocomme c'est le cas présenteme.
QuQuand on est venu pour tourner
lele commercial à Québec, Patrik
m'm'a dit : tu sais, dans le fod
jeje t'aime beaucoup. Je lui dis
quque moi aussi. Quand Patrick
ététait dans les Canadiens,
j'j'étais un vétéran. On a eu ds
bobons moments. Avant que ça
ararrive cette histoire, quand
SeSerge Savard était en poste, l
y y avait eu des rumeurs que
PaPatrick soit échangé. Je pense
quque les 10 années où Patrick a
étété avec les Canadiens, Dieu
sasait qu'il a fait un travail
exextraordinaire. Je pense que a
prpression commençait à le grugr
trtranquillement. Dans le fond,e
pepense qu'on ne l'a pas échangé
dadans un club de dernière
poposition, on l'a échangé au
CoColorado il eut la chance de
gagagner une coupe tannée.
- - Petite question, est-ce que
c'c'est une vraie réconciliation
ouou c'est juste pour la
pupublicité?
- - On a joué au golf ensemble
avavant l'entrevue qui va passer
cece soir à RDS. On a eu du
plplaisir. On agents et d'OK. Je
meme suis informé des remparts e
QuQuébec. Sérieusement, pour cex
ququi pensent confesseur pour la
pupublicité, l'amitié est reven.
- - Ou pour l'argent. Vous n'avz
papas dû recevoir quatre ou cinq
sosous pour cent. Un gros cachet
j'j'imagine.
- - C'est pas pire. Ça paye la
gogomme, disons.
- - Vous n'avez pas fait ça pour
l'l'argent, oui ça aide à
acaccepter, mais c'est une vraie
réréconciliation.
- - Dans le fond, j'ai un
rerestaurant ça fait 40 au lac
SaSaint-Jean. Et Uber Eat va air
leles restaurateurs durant la
COCOVID qui en ont vraiment
ararraché. Ça va permettre d'avr
unune bonne percée au Québec.
- - Comme aujourd'hui et la
jojournée où les gens revoient e
momonde, sur les terrasses, une
jojournée de déconfinement, il a
ququelque chose de symbolique. i
vovous deux, vous êtes des
cacaractères forts et que vous
ararrivez à faire la paix, ça vt
didire qu'on peut faire ça dans
nonotre vie aussi. Ça peut arrir
dede rappeler quelqu'un à qui on
n'n'a pas parlé depuis 20 ans.
- - C'est un très bon point.
PaPatrick et moi en avons parlé
auaussi. En faisant ça, ça va
momontrer aux gens qu'avec la
COCOVID, il y a eu beaucoup de
prproblèmes dans des familles, s
didiscussions qui n'ont pas eu
lilieu ou des gens qui ne se
paparlaient pas. Je pense qu'au
QuQuébec, on veut donner l'exeme
enen se réconciliant. Le monde a
didire : si Tremblay est roi le
fofond, nous aussi on peut le
fafaire. Si on peut allumer les
gegens de ce côté, on va avoir
fafait notre travail.
- - Vous avait divisé le Québec.
- - C'est sur. Je sens vraiment
unune réunification. Sur Twitter
dedepuis deux jours, c'est
inincroyable. C'est pas mal plus
popositifs que négatifs. On va
écécouter un petit extrait de
PaPatrick Roy.
DaDave Morissette, pendant 28
miminutes. On va écouter un très
pepetit bout.
PAPATRICK ROY, gardien de but,
CaCanadiens de Montréal
- - Moi, c'est... je suis vraimt
cocontent de ce rapprochement-l.
OnOn s'est croisés, là,
dadans la dernière année
àà quelques occasions
enen Floride, à Quail Ridge.
OnOn se saluait, etc.
MaMais il y avait... t'sais,
onon était comme comme un peu...
unun malaise. Puis, quand même e
MaMario me dirait : "Pat, j'aurs
ddû t'enlever avant", bon, OK,
paparfait, merci Mario, je suis
cocontent de l'entendre, mais...
MoMoi aussi, là, il faut que
meme regarde dans le miroir!
"P"Pas besoin de lever les bras,
PaPat! Prends ta pilule, là..."
- - Chacun a fait des erreurs.
C'C'est ce qu'il a dit et c'este
quque vous avez dit tout à
l'l'heure.
- - Moi de mon côté et lui de sn
ccôté.
- - Pour les Canadiens, c'est bn
cocomme relations publiques, de
jojoueurs mythiques, les gros
jojoueurs qui se réconcilient.
SuSur la glace, est-ce que ça va
papasser?
- - J'espère. Ce n'est pas fini.
EtEt j'espère que les Canadiensa
cocontinuer de la même façon
ququ'ils ont jouée dans le match
nunuméro cinq à Toronto. On ne
sasait jamais quel club qui va
sosortir. Demain soir, il va y
avavoir 2500 personnes dans le
CeCentre Bell, alors je pense qe
leles joueurs du Canadien n'ont
papas d'autre choix que de sortr
gogonfler à bloc pour essayer
d'd'avoir un match numéro sept à
ToToronto. On sait jamais qui pt
ararriver.
- - 2500 billets, est-ce qu'on
n'n'aurait pas dû les donner à s
ememployés de la santé? Il y a s
ppères qui s's'en vont à 12 000.
- - Ces fous, je ne paierai pas2
0 000 $ pour deux billets. On
auaurait pu donner ça aux gens e
lala santé ou à des gens qui sot
momoins dans les moyens qui n'ot
jajamais été au Centre Bell. Mas
c'c'est leur décision à.
- - Mari